Doutor, você acha que os alimentos de
origem animal pioram as doenças
autoimunes? Olá, pessoal. Que bom estar
aqui com vocês mais uma vez. Hoje vamos
conversar sobre um tema que tem gerado
muita polêmica e desinformação nas redes
sociais. A relação entre alimentos de
origem animal e doenças autoimunes. Sabe
aquela amiga que te disse que parou de
comer carne melhorou da artrite? Ou
aquele parente que jura que a dieta
carnívora curou a psoríase? Pois é.
Vamos destrinchar tudo isso hoje com
muita ciência e sem terrorismo.
Primeiro, vamos entender o que acontece
no nosso corpo quando temos uma doença
autoimune. É como se o nosso sistema de
defesa ficasse meio confuso, OK? Tipo
quando você acorda de madrugada e
confunde o chinelo com a barata. Só que
nesse caso, o corpo confunde nossas
próprias células com invasores e começa
a atacar. Isso gera uma inflamação
crônica que pode afetar diversos órgãos
e sistemas. E aí que entra a questão da
alimentação. Por que o que comemos pode
tanto jogar lenha na fogueira dessa
inflamação quanto ajudar a pagar o
incêndio? Agora vem a pergunta de 1
milhão de dólares. Carne vermelha é vilã
ou mocinha nessa história? Olha, não dá
para ser 880. Algumas pesquisas mostram
que carnes vermelhas têm sim um
potencial inflamatório. É como se elas
mandassem um sinalzinho pro corpo
dizendo: "Ei, vamos produzir mais
substâncias inflamatórias." Mas tá longe
de ser um consenso. Há muita contradição
ainda nos estudos. Por precaução, é bom
evitar o costume de carne vermelha mais
de três vezes por semana. Portanto, não
precisa entrar em pânico e virar
vegetariano de uma hora para outra. O
problema não é a carne em si, mas pode
ser o excesso ou a qualidade. Então,
comer churrasco em excesso todos os dias
pode ser um problema para muitas
pessoas. Agora deixa eu te contar uma
história interessante. Algumas pessoas
relatam melhora absurda dos sintomas
quando cortam completamente os produtos
animais, enquanto outras juram que a
dieta carnívora foi a solução, foi a
salvação. Tem muitos médicos que
aderiram a dieta carnívora porque foram
muito eficientes na resolução de doenças
autoimunes. Então, como é que pode tudo
isso? É que cada organismo é único, meu
povo. O que funciona para fulana pode
não funcionar pra cicrana. Então, quando
alguém corta todos os vegetais e come só
carne e víceras, pode estar eliminando
alguns alimentos que estão causando
sensibilidade, querendo ou não, tipo
glúten, lectinas e outros compostos
vegetais que podem irritar o intestino
de algumas pessoas. Por outro lado,
quando alguém vira vegetariano e
melhora, pode ser porque aumentou o
consumo de antioxidantes, fibras,
compostos antiinflamatórios presentes
nos vegetais, além de reduzir a gordura
saturada, que eu não acredito que seja
vilã, mas muitas pessoas pensam que é.
Mas vamos aos fatos científicos, porque
aqui a gente não trabalha com achismo.
Então, estudos mostram que o excesso de
carne vermelha pode alterar a microbiota
intestinal, aquelas bactérias do bem que
moram no nosso intestino. E olha que
interessante, o intestino é tipo cartel
general de nosso sistema imunológico.
Quando a flora intestinal fica
desequilibrada, pode aumentar a
permeabilidade intestinal, o famoso
intestino hiperpermeável, permitindo que
substâncias que deveriam estar dentro do
intestino, ficar ali mesmo, vão pra
corrente sanguínea e causem mais
inflamação. Então, qual que é a melhor
estratégia? A ciência aponta que uma
dieta anti-inflamatória equilibrada é o
caminho mais seguro. E sabe qual dieta
ganha disparada em todos os rankings? A
mais estudada de todas? a mediterrânea.
Essa dieta não exclui completamente a
proteína animal, mas prioriza peixes
ricos em ômega-3, como salmão e
sardinha, que tem propriedades
antiinflamatórias comprovadas. A carne
vermelha entra em pequenas quantidades,
tipo uma ou duas vezes por semana, e
sempre acompanhada de muitos vegetais,
azeite de oliva, grãos integrais e
frutas. Agora vou dar umas dicas
práticas para vocês aplicarem já no dia
a dia. Se você tem uma doença autoimune
e quer melhorar a sua alimentação, anota
aí. Primeiro, reduza a frequência de
carne vermelha para no máximo duas a
três vezes por semana. E quando for
comer, escolhe cortes adequados. Evite
preparações excessivamente gordurosas ou
queimadas. Segundo, aumente o consumo de
peixes gordurosos. Aquele salmonzinho,
atum, sardinha, cavalinha, arenque são
verdadeiros remédios naturais contra a
inflamação. Terceiro, capriche nos
vegetais coloridos. Quanto mais cor no
seu prato, mais antioxidantes você está
consumindo. E não esqueça das frutas
vermelhas, morango, mestilo, framboesa,
são poderosos antiflamatórios. Aqui no
Brasil nós temos o nossa berry nacional,
o açaí. Quarto, invista em gorduras
boas, azeite de oliva extrav, abacate,
castanhas e sementes, eles ajudam a
modular a resposta inflamatória do
corpo. Tem mais uma coisa importante,
não é só o que você come, mas como você
come. Comer correndo, estressado, sem
mastigar direito, isso também inflama. O
corpo precisa estar relaxado para
digerir bem os alimentos. Ah, e aquela
história de que carne apodrece o
intestino, eu não acredito nisso. O
nosso tema digestivo ou digestório é
perfeitamente capaz de processar
proteínas animais. O problema é que
quando comemos em excesso, aí sim pode
haver uma fumentação e desconforto, mas
pode acontecer com vegetais também.
Agora, se você está pensando em fazer
mudanças radicais na dieta, tipo virar
carnívoro ou cortar toda a proteína
animal ou mesmo cortar todos os vegetais
ou todas as carnes, primeiro converse
com um profissional, porque cada casa é
um caso e o que você pode estar fazendo
não pode ser bom para você. O que é
ótimo pro seu vizinho pode não ser bom
para você. E olha, não adianta comer
direitinho e continuar bebendo todo fim
de semana, fumando, dormindo mal. A
inflamação é multifatorial, depende de
vários aspectos do nosso estilo de vida.
E para finalizar, eu quero deixar bem
claro, não existe alimento milagroso nem
dieta que cure todos com doença
autoimune. O que existe é o conjunto de
hábitos que podemos usar para ajudar a
controlar os sintomas e melhorar a
qualidade de vida. A proteína animal
pode fazer parte de uma dieta saudável
para quem tem doença autoimune. Sim,
lógico que sim, mas com moderação,
qualidade, sempre priorizando o
equilíbrio. Mas você pode sempre tentar
uma dieta vegana ou uma dieta carnívora,
se você quiser, o teste está valendo.
Lembre-se, o extremismo nutricional
raramente a resposta. O segredo está
geralmente na individualização e no
acompanhamento médico profissional
adequado. Espero que essas informações
tenham ajudado vocês a entender melhor
esse tema tão complexo. Se gostarem,
deixe o seu like, compartilhe com que
precisa essa informação e me contem nos
comentários. Vocês notaram alguma
diferença sintomas mudando a
alimentação? Um abraço e até a próxima.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
dor além do se volvar.